[Musica]
questo è il luogo più isolato e remoto e
inospitale che possiamo trovare sul
pianeta terra
questo è l'antartide io ho trascorso qui
a un anno
da novembre 2018 a novembre 2019 ero qua
per lavoro ma è stata un'esperienza con
i suoi lati positivi e negativi che mi
ha permesso di reagire di capire quanto
l'uomo sia piccolo rispetto alla natura
di quanto sia importante fare rete tra
di noi e se è importante reagire per
migliorare le nostre condizioni di vita
io ho trascorso il mio anno a concordia
è una stazione italo francese gestita
dal pnr a e da lì per la quale è
collocata a più di mille chilometri
dalla costa ea 3.000 metri sul livello
del mare
essa è stata costruita a inizi degli
anni duemila è ovviamente al suo interno
ha tutto il necessario per sopravvivere
quindi l'ospedale la zona radio per le
comunicazioni
[Musica]
il ristorante e la zona tecnica per
riscaldamento e acqua vivere qua
significa affrontare dei problemi ad
esempio fisici pensiamo che non c'è
alternanza giorno notte
l'altitudine significa carenza di
ossigeno significa anche aria secca qua
ma soprattutto ovviamente il freddo
d'estate da novembre quindi a febbraio
le temperature hanno una media
all'incirca di meno 25 nel periodo di
natale 2018 abbiamo avuto un record di
caldo di meno 14.7 d'inverno invece da
febbraio a novembre le temperature
scende
sono anche fino almeno 80 la media più o
meno e meno 60 e io ho potuto
sperimentare meno 83 misurati e meno 104
percepiti quindi ovviamente quando
usciamo siamo dei pupazzi
irriconoscibili abbiamo vari strati di
abbigliamento tecnico e possiamo
impiegare anche cinque minuti per
vestirci questa foto è stata presa dopo
pochi minuti in cui avevo scoperto gli
occhi sono stati sufficienti perché le
ciglia gelasse roe si appiccica 0 tra di
loro e la pelle iniziasse a bruciare
altri problemi sono ad esempio problemi
psicologici come la lontananza da casa
io ero lontana a 15mila chilometri dalla
mia famiglia è impossibile tornare
durante questo anno ma soprattutto la
convivenza un po là abbiamo sperimentato
la convivenza durante l'off dow quindi
pensate questo luogo in 60 70 persone
d'estate e d'inverno invece rimaniamo
per nove mesi in 13 quindi un gruppo
ristretto quasi una famiglia in cui però
dobbiamo ricreare delle regole per
convivere pacificamente e quindi oltre
al lavoro è importante avere anche dei
momenti di svago questi momenti ci sono
un po ricordare quella che per voi è la
vita di tutti i giorni e noi perdiamo
invece questa normalità
uno dei momenti erano le guide al
simulatore della soyuz che in realtà è
la navicella che trasporta gli
astronauti dalla terra alla stazione
spaziale internazionale e l'agenzia
spaziale europea a questo simulatore a
concordia per studiare come il nostro
cervello i nostri muscoli cambiano e
reagiscono durante il periodo di
isolamento per noi era diventato come
giocare a the videogame altri momenti di
svago che permettono anche di fare
in realtà sono ad esempio i momenti in
cucina la palestra le pulizie della
stazione è il mio momento preferito
quando abbiamo girato il film per
l'antartico inter film festival in cui
abbiamo fatto una parodia antartica di
colmi medi delle cheerleader di miami e
poi gli ultimo che non è stato in realtà
un momento di divertimento in cui il
fuoco ad aprile ci ricorda che questo è
l'ultimo cartone di latte e non lo
avremmo rivisto fino a novembre ma
perché ero là
ero là per lavorare ovviamente ero il
primo anello di questa lunga catena che
è la ricerca per il cambiamento
climatico
ero là per raccogliere campioni di neve
in superficie e in profondità fino a un
metro e per raccogliere campioni di
particolato atmosferico su appositi
filtri ma perché è importante fare
questo questo significa studiare l'area
ed è importante studiare l'area perché
la respiriamo e perché essa dipende da
noi
l'area anche se non lo vediamo occhio
nudo è composta da degas l'ossigeno
ovviamente anidride carbonica altri è
composta anche da il particolato
atmosferico quindi particelle solide
come il pm10 e questi hanno una
concentrazione naturale e sono in
equilibrio tra di loro equilibrio molto
delicato che noi possiamo e stiamo
alterando introducendo emettendo
sostanze la sostanza più famosa di cui
parliamo sempre è l'anidride carbonica
quindi immettendo grandi concentrazioni
di anidride carbonica provochiamo
l'effetto serra che ha come conseguenza
principale quella dell'aumento delle
temperature ma a questo punto vi
chiedete perché
vediamo in antartide perché così lontano
perché la con i campioni che raccogliamo
adesso capiamo se l'inquinamento che
produciamo noi nei nostri continenti
riesce ad arrivare fin là l'antartide è
un laboratorio all'aria aperta il
continente pisolato e quindi è
importante capire se e come il nostro
inquinamento arriva ma soprattutto è
fondamentale perché possiamo studiare il
clima del passato cioè possiamo avere
informazioni sulla composizione
atmosferica e le condizioni climatiche
fino a migliaia o addirittura un milione
di anni fa questo si fa tramite
carotaggi carotaggio significa prelevare
dal ghiacciaio una carota quindi un
cilindro di ghiaccio all'interno del
quale possiamo trovare quei gas e quel
particolato atmosferico che dicevamo
prima perché esiste uno scambio tra
l'area e la neve superficiale e quindi
questi rimangono intrappolati nel
ghiaccio che si forma poi a partire da
questa neve uno dei progetti più
importanti che è stato fatto proprio a
concordia epica progetto che ha previsto
il carotaggio fino a 3.000 metri di
profondità e che ha permesso di studiare
il clima fino a 800 mila anni fa
questo è un grafico che è stato prodotto
poi dalle analisi della carota il quale
fa vedere appunto come in questi 800
mila anni
la temperatura e la concentrazione di
anidride carbonica siano cambiati nel
tempo e sono stati individuati otto
cicli glaciali e interglaciali cioè otto
cicli in cui la temperatura come
possiamo vedere si alza e si abbassa di
molto ma le cause sono naturali le
teorie
di queste cause ad esempio riguardano la
teoria della tettonica a placche o
dell'inclinazione dell'asse terrestre
rispetto a la radiazione solare e
vediamo che comunque l'andamento è un
andamento ciclico appunto da notare
importante il valore massimo della co2
che è di 300 parti per milione quindi
per cause naturali in un periodo
interglaciale che ha un periodo che
stiamo vivendo anche noi questo è
importante perché questi dati vecchi
prima dell'uomo li possiamo confrontare
con i dati di oggi per capire cosa sta
succedendo
questo è un grafico che è sul sito della
nasa pubblico che ci fa vedere come
giorno per giorno aumenta la
concentrazione di anidride carbonica
nell'atmosfera
quest'anno abbiamo già raggiunto 420
parti per milioni cioè abbiamo già
superato il massimo causato da cause
naturali e lo abbiamo superato in
decenni non in centinaia non in migliaia
di anni
così la temperatura siamo a più un grado
il valore soglia di pericolo è posto a
più un grado e mezzo è il valore oltre
il quale la comunità scientifica prevede
che le condizioni di vita per l'uomo
diventino quasi invivibile temperature
che continuano a crescere e sia molto
molto più complicato di adesso cambiare
rotta e bloccare questo riscaldamento
quindi a questo punto voi giustamente
potreste dire quindi e io beh elio e noi
innanzitutto siamo attori attivi nella
causa in ciò che provoca il cambiamento
climatico ma siamo anche le vittime
delle conseguenze
nessuno di noi ovviamente escluso dalle
conseguenze del cambiamento climatico
conseguenze che riguardano questi sono
solo alcuni
dei settori ma ad esempio appunto
pensiamo alla salute umana
comunque noi l'area la respiriamo entra
nel nostro sistema respiratorio
questo vuol dire che se sono presenti
molecole pericolose possono causare
malattie a partire anche dalla sma ed
allergie
pensiamo che la natura è presidente gli
antibiotici su alcuni batteri non
funzionano più
i batteri sono diventati antibiotico
resistenti
i virus sono in grado di adattarsi
quindi possono causare malattie che è
difficile affrontare la malnutrizione la
povertà migrazioni ovviamente per
cercare condizioni migliori quindi
problemi politici problemi di aiuti
umanitari lo scioglimento dei ghiacci
nell'artico è quello che comunque viene
discusso più frequentemente è un
problema enorme sia per gli animali che
per le popolazioni dell'artico
ma anche dal punto di vista economico e
commerciale scioglimento dei ghiacciai
anche nelle alpi che ha come una delle
cause principali l'innalzamento del
livello del mare
perché questo ghiaccio sciolto deve
andare da qualche parte
poi alte temperature causano
desertificazione quindi perdiamo terreno
non possiamo coltivarlo perdiamo quindi
una risorsa di cibo quindi a questo
punto cosa dobbiamo fare
reagire questa è la foto che per me
rappresenta la mia reazione personale in
antartide e mi piace associare una
citazione di un libro di neo acqua che
parla del silenzio perché in questo
luogo il silenzio quasi assordante senti
solo il tuo respiro e il tuo cuore
in questo passo noacco dice il cielo e
la terra si mescolavano il deserto fa
questo ci pone davanti ai nostri
pensieri più intimi e sembra sussurrare
all'orecchio conosci te stesso ed è
quello che succede ai molto tempo da
trascorrere con te e quindi io sono
riuscita a capire nel bene e nel male le
mie debolezze i miei punti di forza sono
anche riuscite a capire appunto quanto
l'uomo sia piccolo rispetto alla natura
ma quanto male quindi anche quanto bene
possa fargli e quanto sia importante
fare rete sociale sia per la vita di
tutti i giorni quindi le amicizie con la
famiglia sia però anche stare insieme
per reagire aiutarci l'un l'altro per
migliorare le nostre condizioni di vita
e qui quindi poi si passa a un reato
professionale che parte dal voler
divulgare dal voler aiutare le persone a
capire a interessarsi ea reagire
soprattutto con le scuole con i bambini
perché comunque loro saranno gli attori
del domani
ed è giusto lasciare alle future
generazioni una terra vivibile il
progetto a cui tengo particolarmente è
stato fatto con una scuola elementare
del mio paese ho incontrato i bambini
prima di partire quando sono tornata
gennaio e li ho contattati poi durante
l'anno a distanza ed è stato importante
appunto incuriosirli alla scienza
all'ambiente spiegargli cosa stesse
succedendo e fare in modo appunto che
sin da piccoli si attivino a questo poi
si associa un reakt della vita
quotidiana che quello che tutti noi
dovremmo avere è basilare chiamiamolo
così quindi fare attenzione a cosa
mangiamo seguire la stagionalità della
frutta e della verdura
o del pesce anche stare attenti alla
fonte da cui prendiamo il nostro cibo
stare attenti agli imballaggi ridurli
evitare l'eccessivo consumismo ridurre
il consumo di plastica usare prodotti
per la persona e l'ambiente che siano
più sostenibili possibili è difficile
anch'io ho difficoltà e ne sono
straconvinta di quello che faccio ma
difficile non significa impossibile e
non pensate che siete uno tra tanti
perché se ci sogniamo siamo una comunità
e dobbiamo agire come tale è sì vabbè i
grandi cambiamenti devono provenire
dalle politiche quindi l'energia le
aziende gli allevamenti intensivi
ma noi dobbiamo mostrare che tipo di
società vogliamo che tipo di vita
sostenibile vogliamo dobbiamo dare
l'esempio
questo perché ci dobbiamo ricordare due
cose fondamentali la prima è che la
natura il residente si adatta cambia
sopravvive anche all'uomo la seconda
come ha detto parmitano è che la cosa
più fragile
siamo noi uomini grazie
[Applauso]